our main story tonight concerns voting
it is the subject of countless election
psas which are always basically the same
celebrities essentially begging you to
vote but in 1988 there was a strikingly
different one all i'm going to say about
this is there is a surprise at the end
and also at the beginning
[Music]
200 years ago the constitution of the
united states suggested a very simple
way to keep fools like these out of our
government
[Music]
a reminder from members only
holy
what are you doing members only that is
a bold move putting your name so close
to hitler although you know what i will
say it does actually fit pretty well
considering that members only would have
been a perfect slogan for the nazis
but i want to talk to you about voting
because as you undoubtedly know the
latest attack on voting rights in
america is well underway
a new report from the brennan center
shows that between january and july
these 18 states passed 30 laws that
restrict voter access they include
crackdowns on mail-in and early voting
harsher voter id requirements and voter
roll purges yeah it's true all those
states passed laws that make it harder
for people to vote and if anyone is
surprised to see new hampshire up there
let me just remind you it's a state
that's 88 white with a republican
governor and no adult seat belt law sure
they present themselves as charming but
deep down they are basically just
florida with foliage that is it
and some of the biggest efforts to
undermine voting rights have been
concentrated in the closest states in
last year's election especially these
three where biden's combined margin of
victory was less than 43 000 votes if
they had gone the other way trump would
still be president right now meaning
kovid would be even worse we'd be at war
with i don't know let's say luxembourg
and we'd all be living under attorney
general my pillow guy i know things are
bleak right now but depressingly it's
also important to remember this is
technically the better timeline
and i know that those pushing these
bills claim that critics of them are
completely distorting what is inside
them and that any objections could
simply be cleared up with a basic step i
would encourage people to actually read
the bill find out what the facts are
it's time to take a chill pill folks
it's time to read the bill read the bill
there is no voter suppression
read the bill and show me one person
who's eligible to vote that will not be
able to vote you can't find it it's a
lie it's just not there
all right well if that is your criteria
then you obviously win of course no one
is going to find a bill that literally
says this specific person should not be
allowed to vote even though we all know
there is someone who shouldn't be
allowed to vote and it's this guy his
name is brandon caruso his favorite
pizza topping is no source his favorite
season of the wire is i haven't watched
it yet and his list of celebrities he'd
have sex with outside of marriage is
exclusively five times the wheel from
wheel of fortune not vana not pat the
wheel five times one two three four five
brandon
but the thing is if you do actually read
these bills you quickly find they
absolutely make it harder to vote and
particularly for certain people so
tonight we thought we would take a look
at the attack on voting rights and how
best to fight it and let's start with
what is in these bills because it's a
lot for instance in texas where remember
that guy claimed you can't find a single
instance of voter suppression one thing
that bill does is roll back a lot of the
innovative measures put in place during
the pandemic that made voting more
accessible among other things it gets
rid of 24-hour and drive-through voting
both methods that harris county
implemented last year and as the county
clerk who oversaw that election points
out when you look at the precincts where
those methods were most popular it's
clear that the harm is pretty targeted
why are we taking 24-hour voting away
because 56 percent of voters in november
who use 24-hour voting were people of
color and they know that why are we
taking drive-through voting away because
of those voters in 2020 were people of
color
yeah it's pretty obvious who is being
targeted there they may as well say you
can't arrive at a polling place
exhibiting a face in the fenty 300s or
higher sure you're not saying people of
color but we all know what the is
happening
and it's not just drive-through voting
texas and all these other states have
added new barriers to voting by mail
coincidentally just a year after
elections in which the percentage of
black people who voted by mail surged
past white voters meanwhile all these
states have put harsher voter id
requirements in place even though
federal court cases found black and
latino voters in states with harsh laws
disproportionately lacked access to the
types of voter ids required to vote so
already when you do read these bills you
quickly find some in plain view
it's like a second grader playing hide
and seek you're bigger than the coffee
table bud i can see your feet hands full
face and you're giggling very loudly you
didn't do a good job at hiding
and some of those pushing these bills
like this state representative from
georgia even argue that if a law does
make it harder to vote that's not
necessarily a bad thing i do believe
that that voting in this country is a
privilege and it's a right and it's
right as well but it ought to mean
enough where
you could put forth a little bit of
effort in trying to cast your ballot
okay except something can't be a right
and a privilege that you need to work
for because those are two completely
different things for instance it is a
right for brandon caruso to imagine what
hot tordry sex with the wheel of fortune
would be like to imagine climbing on top
of it and taking her all in to think
about the crowd watching him yeah that's
right the studio audience is there and
they're rooting for him because he did
it brandon finally did it he's finally
the wheel
imagining how good that would feel is
brandon's right but actually getting to
grab those pegs and give the wheel a
spin that is a privilege that should
take years of effort
and look
none of this is anything new republicans
have been pushing restrictive voting
laws for years back in 2013 north
carolina crafted a law that made it so
the only acceptable forms of voter id
were the ones disproportionately used by
white people in a bill a federal appeals
court later said targeted
african-american voters with almost
surgical precision which has to be the
second worst context in which to hear
that phrase topped only by surgery look
ma'am
your husband's surgery was
we got in there with almost surgical
precision my team's not a hundred
percent yet but we were really close on
this one
and frequently these laws have been
helped along by well-funded groups like
the heritage foundation whose co-founder
paul weirich famously admitted i don't
want everybody to vote and whose former
president jim demint once approvingly
said in the states where they do have
voter id laws you've actually seen
elections begin to change towards more
conservative candidates pretty much
giving the whole game away there and
heritage is very much still at it just
this year the executive director of
their sister organization heritage
action actually bragged about their role
in pushing this year's new bills we're
working with these state legislators to
make sure they have all of the
information they need to draft the bills
in some cases we actually draft them for
them ayah was a huge victory governor
reynolds signed the bill on march 8th
little fanfare honestly nobody even
noticed my team looked at each other and
were like it can't be that easy
it can't be that easy well hold on there
tj maxx ivanka trump because anyone
saying it can't be that easy to do
anything other than sneaking their own
snacks into the movies absolutely must
be stopped
the point here is this has been a
concerted organized effort over many
years but the reason it now has a much
higher chance of working has to do with
a pair of supreme court decisions that
gutted the landmark 1965 voting rights
act which prohibited racial
discrimination in voting the first
decision shelby county versus holder
basically released these areas which had
a prior history of discriminatory voting
laws from having to run any new ones
past the federal government first before
they took effect and the second one
brnovich versus dnc essentially found
that even if a voting restriction has a
discriminatory impact that in itself
doesn't necessarily violate the voting
rights act those two decisions basically
made it easier for some states to pass
discriminatory laws while at the same
time making it much harder for anyone to
challenge them and given that one of the
dwindling ways that you can still
successfully sue under the vra is by
demonstrating a bill is racially
motivated it is hardly surprising that
those passing these new laws have been
quick to shut down any discussion of
their racial impact in fact in texas in
the midst of debating their new bill
there was this incredible moment
members is a reminder to everyone to be
civil
and respectful of our colleagues
as we debate sb1
the chair would appreciate members not
using the word racism this afternoon
look look
if the word you don't want people to use
is racism i hate to break it to you but
you're doing a racism
someone might have told you that sooner
but in fairness you told them they're
not allowed
a constant theme in debates over these
bills is black elected officials
pointing out their impact and their
white colleagues telling them to be
quiet in arizona back in april they were
debating a bill that makes it hard for
many voters to receive an early ballot
in the mail but watch what happened when
one lawmaker started pointing out the
disproportionate impacts that that would
have
the effect of this bill will make it
harder for independent voters
seniors native americans black brown and
low income people to vote
to each of you point of order in 2022
point of order i have 12 words for you
point of order
show up
point of order show out
point of order
okay you should never shout someone down
when they only want to say 12 words
unless of course those 12 words are his
testicles became swollen his friend was
weeks away from getting married and look
look i know that obviously does not look
good but wait until you see that man's
colleague read from the rule book to
explain his point of order
in accordance with rule 19a no member
shall be permitted to indulge in
personalities use language personally
offensive arraign motives of members
charge deliberate misrepresentation or
use language tending to hold a member of
the house or senate up to contempt and i
feel personally that motives were
arraigned of members including myself
with regards to colored people black
people whatever people this individual
wants to single out
in their ability to vote and i i don't
think it's correct and i think he should
be sat down and he shouldn't be allowed
to speak
oh
all the way off i do not care what
the situation is the very second someone
starts reading you the rules from a
weird tiny book they could just
right off into the sun also for the
record if you say the words coloured
people and it is not immediately
preceded by national association for the
advancement of you are officially in
time out
but republicans cannot just claim that
they are not being racist in pushing
these bills they do still need a reason
for them so what exactly is that reason
well for years they claimed that there
was an epidemic of voter fraud despite
the fact actual instances of that are
incredibly rare so they have now shifted
their justification from something
measurable what people are doing to
something much less tangible what they
are feeling just listen to the
lieutenant governor of texas making that
exact pitch
i've been asked why is his bills needed
very simple
the bill is needed because americans no
longer trust the system
and a country where voters
do not trust the system as a country in
peril yeah okay but you still need a
reason to legislate against something
you can't just do it based on a feeling
if that were the case i would propose a
bill to outlaw tilda swinton why too
creepy she looks like a ghost who knows
exactly how and when you will die but
won't tell you because it's more fun for
her that way
but look i will say despite the fact
state and local officials found the last
election to be the most secure in
american history the truth is many
republicans don't trust the system but
the reason for that might be that people
like dan patrick spent all of last year
calling voting by mail a scam by
democrats to steal the election and
saying like this
look when you have an opportunity to
steal a vote the democrats will take
advantage of it you can swing the
balance easily ed i could give you 10
scenarios but i won't because i don't
want to give anyone ideas how you could
easily steal thousands of votes
oh come on damn
i can give you 10 scenarios but i won't
it's just such an obvious lie it's right
up there with i have a girlfriend she
goes to a different school you wouldn't
know her or i'm five minutes away or
i've never sexually fantasized about
lobsters come on we've all done that
it's natural they're stoic and
terrifying the perfect sexual
combination what are we looking for if
not someone who knows what they want but
also hates you that's lobster's buddy we
want their claws pinching our earlobes
not too hard but honestly
hard you know like when the dentist says
does this hurt and you say no but you
mean yes because you're kind of curious
what this dentist can do when pushed do
you know how many legs a lobster has
i'll tell you a sex amount bong bong
bong bong bong bong bong bong bong that
many me stupid you weaponized ocean
here is
four hit reasons why it would be cool to
adult-sized lobster on holiday
they live a long time meaning that they
know what they're doing their backs are
incredibly strong and responsive i
shouldn't have to explain to you why
that's good sexually they're incapable
of racism and they can't talk and ruin
the mood we ask is this good and they
just sort of wobble their horrible black
eyes around my point here is we all
think about having sex with burdened
unhappy lobsters all the time even in
winter and that is why we should not
listen to dan patrick or honestly
whoever it was i was talking about
earlier i don't remember
but here is the real thing
there is a reason that patrick can give
you 10 scenarios for democrats stealing
elections but no evidence and that is
because despite saying he would pay up
to a million dollars for evidence of
voter fraud he has to put it mildly not
paid out
and local election supervisors
themselves will tell you that these
bills make no sense the florida
supervisors of elections strongly
opposed their state's new bill with one
republican supervisor telling a reporter
it's stupid okay it was a solution
looking for a problem but it's actually
one step worse than that because these
are solutions to problems that have been
deliberately and strategically
manufactured and the game is pretty
obvious here use claims to stir
up baseless fear to pass unnecessary
restrictions targeting particular groups
just look what happened this week the
nonsense audit in arizona came to a
humiliating conclusion that failed to
show yet again that trump was cheated of
victory but its organizers still
recommended the legislature tighten up
the election process to provide
additional certainty going forward
because of course they did it's
all a shameless attempt to get to the
same place
so what can we do to fight all of this
well the good news is there is proposed
legislation addresses many of the
problems that you've seen tonight the
john lewis voting rights advancement act
would restore parts of the vra the
supreme court gutted and more
substantially there is the freedom to
vote act which would among other things
make voting by mail available for every
voter make election day a public holiday
and make automatic voter registration a
national standard it is great
unfortunately mitch mcconnell has
announced that he will filibuster any
attempt to get either of those acts
passed so
if we want to protect the ballot which
we absolutely should we need to end the
filibuster and you would hope that every
national democratic politician would be
absolutely screaming about this but some
are doing the exact opposite joe manchin
has consistently defended the filibuster
and when joe biden was asked if he
supports doing away with it to
specifically protect voting rights this
was his maddening answer
what i don't want to do is get wrapped
up right now in the argument whether or
not this is all about the filibuster or
look the american public you can't stop
them from voting you tried last time
more people voted last time than any
time in american history in the middle
of the worst pandemic in american
history more people did and they showed
up
they're going to show up again they're
going to do it again
sure joe
maybe
or maybe they'll show up and get turned
away because of everything that we've
been talking about here boyne's white
house even reportedly told voting rights
groups that it is possible to out
organize voter suppression but the
problem is it isn't
it just isn't that is what voter
suppression is
as activists and actual organizers will
tell you i'm very upset with president
biden because i feel like he's not
advocating for us in this moment i mean
what i want him to see is is to stop
saying to out organize voter suppression
i want him to support the elimination of
the filibuster i want him to support and
endorse the for the people act because
he's accepted the step up to the plate
we are at a at a crossroads we need
federal assistance immediately if he's
incapable of that he needs to be quiet
and go yeah he's right the solution to
voter suppression cannot be to just vote
for the same reason that the solution to
being locked out of your home can't be
to tell someone just go inside and get
the keys what the are you talking
about i'm locked out
how are you not understanding this
situation
all of this is to say to joe's biden
mansion and any other joe who wants to
skip doing anything significant and
instead rely on the perseverance of the
american spirit stop around and
fix this i know it is tempting to bang
the optimistic drum that more americans
showed up last year than ever before and
by gum they'll do it again but here is
the thing the republicans know that that
might happen that is why they're doing
this
and anyone unwilling to do what it takes
to actually tackle this problem should
and i cannot believe i'm going to borrow
this quote really be sat down and not
allowed to speak
you